wenn du dir das bass des profi wird der
eva maria bast und deg nach halle kommen
einfach wurde ich sehr viel wert legt es
völlig es senioren tür da sie anders
machen
die mission hatte mutter von drei
erwachsenen kindern und geht mit 58 für
ein halbes jahr als au pair nach brüssel
wie ist das wenn man dem leben eine neue
wendung gibt und sich dabei selber
mitnimmt davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
ich frage mich was bringt eine
58-jährige frau und mutter dazu ob herr
zu werden
auf dem sofa das golddorf möchte sich
doch mit durchdachter ist doch klar das
ist nachher einfach nicht gut da einfach
für zu niedrig
denn es braucht wieder eine aufgabe
das ist sie reich hier ist sie
verwurzelt
ihre kinder gehen zwischen eigene wege
sie hat wieder mehr zeit zeit die sie
sinnvoll nutzen will
sie sagt nichts sei wie früher das merke
sie nicht zuletzt bei der verwertung der
äpfel an statt salat im winter herrschen
komplett gemacht und zum dessert helle
köpfe machen der sl verwöhnprogramm ja
ja dass das töten lange zweiter
headliner des vitra des ev nun meldet
sich denise für ein halbes jahr aus
ihrem alten leben ab was treibt sie so
weit weg sie könnte ja auch in der
schweiz ihre lebenserfahrung einbringen
wird in der schweiz seit jahr und tag
und von der schweiz dass er jetzt hatte
domenicali gehabt kann und einfach die
loslösung asche von den anderen gegenden
andere familie aufs land und aus essen
und und frauen software stark wie er
nach der pfalz tätig doch hat die stadt
jetzt land auch wenn ich ihren anderen
reiz von verlegern aber noch lustig
macht
jetzt ist ende oktober bis anfang april
geht sie nach brüssel
was sagt ihr mann andre dazu werde sie
vermissen
[Musik]
ob sie zur sache für messe für messe und
es auch als cd rom
es funktioniert außerdem und stadt
dieses oder jenes danke der grundschüler
gar nicht dazu danke fürs büro geht und
er sagte ja dass sie es vielleicht zum
flughafen ist die ganze familie gekommen
und denise zu verabschieden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das abenteuer beginnt
[Musik]
sie verlässt die schweiz als mutter eine
stunde später kommt sie als op an
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt ob ihr diese
rollenwechsel gelingt
[Musik]
hallo und eine überraschung groß
christa hallo wir ja zum glück nicht so
weit weg
hier wird sie das nächste halbe jahr
wohnen in einem kleinen haus am
stadtrand von brüssel und das sind ihre
schützlinge planer und tristan so wie
schön das ist ein team eines htc das
schenkst du mit so gut
während du nicht bei ihnen ist schläft
die ganze familie im elternschlafzimmer
ihr habt ihr euch zusammen geführt
die erste morgen im neuen zuhause die
familie ein europäischer mix mutter
diana ist deutsche vater herd ist
belgier
die beiden haben sich soeben selbständig
gemacht er als unternehmensberater sie
als expertin für frühkindliche
kommunikation
sie wollen unterstützung im haushalt und
in der kinderbetreuung bewusst holen sie
diese von einer erfahrenen frau also für
mich und sicherlich sagen ist ein werden
jungs oder mädchen überhaupt nicht in
frage warum habe ich nicht mal drüber
nachgedacht
es ist einfach eine ganz andere art von
hilfe wenn man jemanden hat wer im leben
steht und und und also selber familie
hat aber ich habe so das gefühl dass man
mir der nächstes profil auf der bp
website so gut gefallen ich habe so das
gefühl dass das demnächst wirklich dass
so auch macht weil sie weil sie helfen
möchte wo sie gebraucht wird und doch
hat nicht so angesprochen gefunden haben
sie denise über eine agentur die opas
über 50 vermittelt lohn bekommt sie
keinen nur kostenlos nach sechs wochen
bin ich wieder in belgien zu besuchen
[Musik]
inzwischen ist dennis angekommen in
einer welt die ihr vertraut ist und doch
fremd
als dennis ihre kinder groß zog gab es
andere spiele zum beispiel mikado sie
hat es extra nach berlin mitgebracht
da muss ich nicht langweilen und
zuckerkonzentration zügiger und vielem
mehr
das ist also seid mir damals auch in
heißen ländern war sehr gut mit mir
gemacht kann jetzt da eigentlich
freundlich hin
[Musik]
ich war kein licht war kann trainer
dennis selten allein mit den kindern die
eltern arbeiten beide von zu hause aus
der übergang zwischen beruf und
kinderbetreuung ist fließend
[Musik]
da kann etwas mit deutscher abgrenzen
abgeordnete abbas abbas unklar was ich
weiß nicht ob es auch einfach vielleicht
zufall ist dass es das ist klickt wir
haben über ein paar sachen also wir sind
beide sehr offen und ehrlich wenn uns
irgendwie sowas was auffällt oder
irgendwas nicht stimmt wir sagen dass
direkt wir können darüber reden aber ich
kann mir also fast niemanden vorstellen
werden unkomplizierter wäre mädchen
je länger ich dennis begleitet desto
mehr merke ich dass sie diese anpassung
gar nicht so einfach fällt ja
das brauche ich für die grauen ja ja
genau
für dezember ist so hübsch octapharma
stundenplan aber wenn das war dafür das
bad während man darf das benutzen der
logischen ständigen ist nicht glücklich
habe dies mittlerweile geht es aber da
ist noch mehr was du nicht belastet den
eingang ist ja dafür steht das ist
einfach so wie die jeweils oft robin ist
ausgelaufen
es ist sogar etwas ja es ist einfach es
ist einfach sie mit luft die sache damit
luft zum schnuppern
ein ausflug in die innenstadt von
brüssel kommt da gerade recht
[Musik]
seien wir doch mal kitschig ist das ist
einfach spitze
musik
[Musik]
vergeblich
probieren ist da einfach pflicht und die
fällige softkeys auf frisch kommt locker
besseres spitze
das 2 1 für heime mit dem bus sollen
jetzt 12
was machen wir kleinigkeiten eine freude
machen kann wenn es kleinigkeiten für
uns selbstverständlich dass wir fahren
freistadt
st
[Musik]
jetzt kannst du ja
heute auf dem menüplan lachs nudeln
erste parade menüs von denise
[Musik]
mit einer streikwelle sie sich
vielleicht denkt vielleicht das weil ich
näher das wäre ich einfach mehr
spezieller gegangen aber sehr gern phase
vor dem haus wirkungsvollen aktiv
mit am tisch
denn der sohn aus erster ehe des vaters
ihm schmeckt's anderen weniger aber das
wurde mit mir innerlich ja wenn man
einfach bisher gar nicht einfach nach
gerade noch erspart so konzipiert dass
anders ein witz wird eine gasse damals
ja oft können oder mit dem ruhm und mit
dem spieler und ausführlich sind
liquidieren betragen hat so geht's
eigentlich immer es also an das ist nur
einigermaßen sich einigermaßen normal
das ist einfach jedes wohnzimmer und
klickt sieht die kunststoffe nachkochen
ich auch noch so speziell mit dem smiley
dort zum spieler des hauses eigentliches
spielhaus verdammnis endloser der
blattzeit zum wohnen und kochen wenig
benito oder vielleicht bin ich extrem
ich weiß es nicht
und darin sitzen möglichkeit das mal
besprechen
die turiner ja nicht ins innere der
tätig und jedes programm muss athener
eigentlich nur mit mini art mit
mineralwasser hat für den monat oktober
zeige mich als anders machen als lichter
gott
ich frage mich was ist hier der richtige
weg sich einbringen oder schweigen
[Musik]
denise schweigt und geht
sie sagte familie sie habe ein
berufliches angebot in der schweiz
bekommen nach drei monaten bricht sie ab
wie hat dies müsse sie dass du es konnte
also muss kauften ist sich svs das wäre
einfach rasmussen sind macht aktiv
morgen das der idealfall war dir gibt
grusser jeder job los und wäre
eigentlich der haushalte 2 klingt ganz
nach rechts ganz erfolgreiche ganzes zu
wenig von der heimat und bänder läuft
das geschäft auch genau diese gedanken
hat sie der familie nie offenbart ja als
grundsatz sie gesagt sie hat ein
jobangebot gekriegt dass sie also das
für ihr alter einfach sie sagt perfekt
so das kriegt man nicht alle tage das
konnte sie nicht ablehnen
und so habe ich mich gefreut auch für
sie natürlich und das ist die wahrheit
ja ich weiß nichts anderes casino mixi
sind dass es für die frau schwierig ist
das rad gesetzt hat die nämlich muss
hallen und danach regelmäßig al-assad
abschafft oder habe das schaffen nur
ironie und und und und das dass ich nach
einer völligen der reflexion stoff für
sich sagen das ist für den haben sie
nicht verdient dass wir umstellen wo
völlig nach hause kommt
der einsatz war kürzer als geplant
streit gab es nie und schon
sein
aufpassen austrianer mama papa mach das
beste hafenstraße geschätzt werden halt
da ich gut dann sprecht euch auf und
dann dann muss es gehen das musste ja
als auch beim ball
[Musik]
denise ist wieder zurück in der schweiz
das kann jetzt die damen beim 1 möglich
ja dass das hat mir erzählt dank das
wirklich machen wird im volk mit der
familie kliem abgebrochen und mit
einfach auf massive engagement schon zu
gut
[Musik]
jetzt taucht sie wieder in ihr reich ein
hier hat sie das zepter in der hand
[Musik]